what i've been doing in the past 10
years basically
is creating ecosystems to scale
innovation
and that's my passion today
how do we
take technology and innovation and scary
global
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is all about globalization the
israeli ecosystem with the world
specifically with asia meet rani shifron
the ceo of healthier globe
rani is the ceo of healthier globe a
consulting firm and the israeli
representative of taiwanese-based
innovation to industry running launch
pad programs for israeli companies in
taiwan
so running you know
tell me about medical devices
asia startups first you know focusing on
the medical devices side how do you get
yourself involved so deeply with this
world of medical devices and a healthier
world
so
my
training is in engineering and i
also
took
lots of biomedical engineering courses
so that's really how i got started in
a
and was intrigued with the whole
side of
medical devices bringing healthcare
technologies
uh to the world
and helping people
live better lives
were there specific you know events that
led you to become so passionate about
this or is this simply you know academic
curiosity that led you this way
um
well
actually
i
thought of being a doctor all my life
as a child
and then i i saw that i'm not built to
be a doctor so i went in from the other
angle of being an engineer
and basically
i um
was born uh upside down so that did you
basically
they
had a a rough start
in in this world and then and
was
injured
in birth really
so i i think that whole thing has
brought me to the
world of medicine
trying to
bring better health to
and to patients
and into the world
and then
basically i
got involved with early on with startups
and from really from the garage up
before even the word startup was common
and then
and was even more intrigued because that
was the real
business school for me on how to bring
medical devices
to global markets
and i was involved
throughout the years with the two
startup which we grew from basically
zero
to a
a global giant giant i would say as
first companies stayed private
its whole life but the second company we
took public
and we
spun off a technology and then we ended
up getting bought by one of the
uh global giants
and so
throughout that i basically built a
global network
with ecosystems
and to be able to help
companies
and
bring their technologies
outwards
and that's what i've been doing in the
past 10 years basically
is creating ecosystems to scale
innovation
and that's my passion today
how do we
take technology and innovation and scale
globally
so
i'm hearing that the a big part of the
journey was
medical devices and the actual
technology as an engineer and and what
i'm also understanding is in the last 10
years
you're focusing more and more about this
idea of ecosystem
and enabling other technologists and
entrepreneurs break into the global
market and scale globally right
that's that's correct
especially with medical technologies
and with all the
entry barriers
there are regulatory approvals
you know insurance uh reimbursement
and everything else
it's it's uh
it's a very
difficult road to take especially for
startups and they need guidance and they
need mentoring and they need
facilitating
and they need people on the ground
and they basically
i've been involved
a lot of my career i started in
involved in the us
and then in europe and then
focusing in the far east
uh for many years now
because i see the big potential in the
far east the far east for me i include
from india eastward
and when you say india eastward that's
you take all the population that's more
than half the world population
and as far as medical care is concerned
the there's more and more budgets for
that part of the world
so that's why
they're
i saw that as the big potential
and many years ago
um
and had been involved in that
and my involvement
included a lot of work with japan and
korea
singapore china the whole pacific rim
including china
and through the years i saw that
working
with taiwan is
actually the easiest
and because they have a lot of
similarities
to israel as far as they're an island
and and they they need to take care of
themselves
and and help each other out
scale
uh outward
and then therefore the similarities yeah
and the language
they speak a
little in english so it's not like we're
dealing with chinese
right so if we're looking at taiwan
specifically and what's happening with
taiwan in terms of innovation you know
startup ecosystems
how taiwan is placed within asia as well
is it mainly that taiwan is you know an
innovation hub that happens to be in
asia or does it also interact with the
asia ecosystem in more meaningful ways
yeah taiwan interacts
with a lot with the
with the whole
enquiries ecosystem
but they they
they're they were big
in innovation in the semiconductor field
back in 80s and 90s
and part of the problem now where the
government has recognized this five
years ago
was that they've stagnated an innovation
and they needed to rejuvenate innovation
in several different areas to be able to
bring taiwan to try
yeah and then and therefore they created
several different
programs to infuse innovation from the
outside
into taiwan
to be able to help that
they've recognized this as as
a goal
and they're funding
different programs to be able to
and
fuse infusion and
innovation okay i see so for looking
back to medical devices
you know a passion of yours for many
years
what is the big challenge that you're
that you've
learned to overcome
with all your experience about taking
medical devices globally what is the
issue there
okay so so number one
companies need to understand that
they need to
first of all
do clinical validation
on a local level
meaning any country they want to enter
they need to find a key opinion leader
and do a clinical validation could be a
pilot doesn't have to be a full-blown
study
but just to show them
that it works
with that specific population in that
specific region
and and that helps open up the markets
easier the number number two thing is
obviously the regulatory governors each
country has
different regulatory
uh approval processes
and some easier some harder
but
so you need a local player to help you
with the regulatory
and barriers
and tackling that
and then also when
finding the right partner
and finding the right partner is not
just signing up a distributor
because
or you a
bigger company or an oem
because
they won't do the selling for you
okay
or the marketing
you need to
have
your own people on the ground or
representatives to be able to push
and
and train
and you know
convince people of what clinical value
you're bringing
also the main thing here is
a lot of times i see
um
inventions coming out
and
coming from the technical side and not
coming from
the need okay
it always has to come up from the in the
neat side
and let's solve the need
and so coming with another
widget or
gadget that
that is nice to have is not going to do
it
so so there again those many pieces to
the puzzle i call it a multi multi-axle
puzzle
that you have to solve
a in parallel and that's that's where
you know that that's where the big
trick is in
penetrating into my kids
um
finding strategic partners is is is the
second stage
because the fruit they won't partner
with you until you show them that it
works
and
you know and
at least there's several different
geographies
so
so again it's a it's a tactical and
strategical play
in order to be able to come into
the markets
and what i've
done with taiwan is we actually
partnered with
many of the different hospital chains
there
and in order to do a local work
taiwan also has
been
accumulating uh all of the
population and medical records for the
last 30 years like israel
so there's a lot of
parallel things here
taiwan is
one of the leading
countries as far as medical care is
concerned
and so it's it's a great
um sandbox i would say
for companies to come in
and to validate
and
to collaborate
and to expand globally i see taiwan as
the gateway for the far east today
and i think it's it
there's
distinct advantages of working in taiwan
and especially nowadays when
china
is uh
we're not really sure how to deal with
china so when
again have you utilized taiwan as a as a
jumping board into many different
countries like japan korea
and all the other
parts of the far east
so as we know the
the israeli ecosystem is very much on
the technology side
we have some great
things in medical coming out of israel
but but it's very tech focused and one
thing that i mentioned before that
that i wanted to touch
to to retouch on is this idea of
validation of the problem before running
through the technology side and
and putting the the problem first and
the solution first before the complexity
of the technology
what have you learned to be successful
in this regard you know some strategies
that would enable a team
even if it's a very deep tech team to to
identify and validate the right problem
before running full steam on a potential
technology that they think may be
worthwhile
i i think speaking to the market
early on even if it's just
on
on paper i'd be on paper meaning
and that you don't even have anything
speaking to the end users
potential end users
is very valuable and saves a lot of time
because sometimes what you think is
probably the best solution the same no
it's nice to have i don't really need
this
but if you can do this
change a little bit there this is what i
need you know to solve my
daily problems uh
in the or
or any other settings
so so so it's it's it's really about uh
throughout the whole process not just
early on throughout the whole process
always try to get as much feedback as
possible from end users
um
keep them in the loop
i mean
they will be your number one promoters
once you come out with the product
because
they feel involved
right
definitely
if you're looking today in your role
within the ecosystem and you've
mentioned that today are very much
involved with
supporting creating and pushing forward
ecosystems
where where is the big value attitude of
your work with different organizations
well again
being able to expose company to the
whole ecosystem whether it's
the clinical side the manufacturing side
even the design side
the r d side
you know for future and generation of
the product
a
being able to be connected to that whole
ecosystem
and connecting the companies
very easily hey
you should talk to him or you should
talk to them
a
is
i find that as
the best the gratifying thing and also
it saves a lot of times for companies
anyways so it's it's it's again it's
the the whole process
whether it's on clinical development on
the technology development on
the manufacturing and then on the
scaling how do you scale this the
solution globally
and
that's where
that's where i come in is trying to help
companies
and
solve all all those different questions
of the puzzle
fantastic
if you had to look at you know
medical device entrepreneurship and
technologies
in the next few years what what are the
you know the big milestones that were
we're going to reach and they're also a
big in digital health and remote
monitoring
where are the big
milestones that we can expect in the
next few years from your perspective
well it's already started the ai big
data machine learning revolution
is bringing about
personalized medicine
okay
so
it won't be one solution fits all it'll
be
okay let's see what your problem is
let's see how we personalize
the solution the medical solution for
you even in the drug side it won't be
one pill fits all and it'll be
different drugs for different people
meaning
as far as the
amount of of the drug itself so
you won't be giving
you know
and not in different
all patients the same the same drugs
and so i i think
a part of the uh
the revolution we're seeing uh well it's
obviously ai which was giving us a lot
of solutions already
but i think the pharmaceutical industry
is coming on board late
into the game
and that's where the big jump is gonna
take place as far as
solving
that and what will be is
we'll see people living longer
better
better lives
and longer so i guess
that has another
an end to that uh economic hand as far
as how do you sustain
the population but that and that
for a different topic
ronnie thank you very much uh for your
time and for your work and and then
working on solutions that make people
healthier live better lives longer and i
love the
intersection here of both the
the world that you're in but also
you know the locations and what you're
talking about and your understanding of
the potential and specifically taiwan
and
and and the the understanding the
complexity of
taking these medical devices globally
making a global impact so ronnie thank
you very very much stay safe and stay
healthy and until next time
thank you michael and you too bye-bye
thank you
[Music]